I think it's well understood by uh the
audience of this show that I am not
exactly a big fan of Republican
presidential candidate Nikki Haley In
fairness I'm not a fan of any politician
even the few that I support politicians
are not professional athletes or pop
stars they shouldn't have fans but
either way uh my feelings about Nikki
Haley are generally quite negative her
whole brand is basically George Bush in
a pants suit which is a brand that I not
only find viscerally repulsive but also
one that couldn't possibly be more out
of step and out of touch in fact it's
worse than George in a pantu because
George Bush was at least kind of likable
in a goofy bumbling neocon Warhawk kind
of way Haley has the neocon Warhawk part
down but not the likable part so she's
George Bush with less charm and more
shrillness uh basically it's like the
the most unappealing sales pitch you
could possibly come up with in my
opinion but it's not just my opinion
many conservatives feel the same way of
course especially after Haley 's most
recent controversy appearing on Fox News
yesterday the presidential hopeful
called for the government to unmask and
monitor all Anonymous accounts on every
social media platform a plan that sounds
bad when you hear it summarized and then
somehow gets even worse when she
explains it in more detail listen when I
get into office the first thing we have
to do social media accounts social media
companies they have to show America
their algorithms let us see why they're
pushing what they're pushing the second
thing is every person on social media
should be verified by their name that's
first of all it's a national security
threat when you do that all of a sudden
people have to stand by what they say
and it gets rid of the Russian Bots the
Iranian Bots and the Chinese Bots and
then you're going to get some civility
when people know their name is next to
what they say accountability and they
know their pastor and their family memb
is going to see it it's going to help
our kids and it's going to help our
country so this is um not just something
she wants wants to do but it's a it's a
day one priority when she first gets
into the White House which she never
will the first thing she wants to do is
is to start exposing and cataloging
loging all of those dastardly Anonymous
accounts Biden's doj just prosecuted a
man for posting a joke about Hillary
Clinton with his Anonymous account and
we talked about this on the show they
sentenced him to seven months in federal
prison Haley has as far as I know
expressed no concern over that
outrageous miscarriage of justice that
blatant assault on the First Amendment
instead she wants to she wants to make
it easier for the federal government to
do that
again
now the kind of general complaint about
Anonymous accounts is one that years ago
um I would have I would have agreed with
now I never would have called it a
national security threat or advocated
for the government to forcibly unmask
them but I did buy into the idea that
conversations online would be more
productive if everybody had their real
name attached to whatever they're saying
um it's easy you know to see why a
non-anonymous person can find it
annoying when Anonymous people take pot
shots from behind the cover of their
fake name and their Anime Avatar or
whatever but you know I kind of changed
my view on this topic because of course
not every Anonymous person is a dumb
Troll and plenty of people who are not
Anonymous are still dumb trolls um I'm
not sure there's any real evidence that
people online are suddenly more
thoughtful and civil when they go by
their real name ultimately it's not
anonymity that enables so many people on
social media to conduct themselves like
Despicable clowns rather it's the screen
separating them from everyone they're
engaging with it is the separation it's
the
disconnect that uh gives rise to most of
the stuff and that's just the nature of
the beast that's that's the internet
there's nothing you can do about that
besides the problem with online
discourse uh much like the problem with
the discourse in Washington DC it's it's
not that it lacks
civility the problem on the internet
anyway is that usually this discussion
is loud and stupid and and focused on
the wrong
things but there are plenty of loud
stupid off-topic people ruining the
conversation while proudly posting all
that stuff with their real names and
faces again there's no reason to think
that taking away anonymity will suddenly
make people respectful and thoughtful
the Internet is just not a place for
that kind of conversation and never has
been and never will
be in any case there are I've realized
very good reasons for people to be
anonymous it's easy for someone like me
to cast all Anonymous accounts as
cowardly trolls it's easy for Nikki
Haley to take that position we are both
public figures whose employment will not
be threatened by us expressing our
political views our whole public Persona
is based around the expression of our
views now that's not to say that I don't
suffer very real personal consequences
for it but at least my livelihood is not
threatened for many people in this
country the situation is quite different
if they don't have the cover of
anonymity then they will not be able to
engage at all they will not be able to
share their views at all they face being
fired ostracized potentially even worse
and not for saying horrible
objectionable things but simply for
expressing viewpoints that are not
approved by mainstream liberal Society
the holidays are coming up fast and
while you're out shopping for your kids
family and friends don't forget to shop
for your pets too I never do give your
dog the gift of a healthier and happier
life with rough greens natural Dr Dennis
black the founder of Ruff greens is
focused on improving the health of every
dog in America before I started feeding
my dog Ruff greens I had no idea that
dog food is dead food it contains very
little nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green so let
rough greens bring your dogs food back
to life rough greens is a supplement
that contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food you just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
greens and supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are wheat and that
goes for dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis
black is so confident Ruff greens will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jump start trial bag
so your dog can try it that's a free
jump trial bag delivered straight to
your door just a few business days go to
Ru greens.com or call 844 ru700 that's
rfffg greens.com or call 844 rough 700
today strip away anonymity and you will
ensure that the left Wing views are like
the only ones that dominate on every
platform even more than they already do
because those are the only views that a
person with a normal job can comfortably
expressed without fear of reprisal or
loss of livelihood now it would be much
better if we lived in a country where
anonymity was not necessary it would be
better if everyone could post online
under their real name but uh that is not
the country we live in now of course
this is all somewhat academic because
whether there is good reason to use
anonymous accounts or not and I think
there is the biggest issue with Haley's
proposal is that she wants the federal
government to force the issue she is
advocating for a massive expansion of
the surveillance State she wants to
further empower the federal government
to crack down on speech that it deems a
threat or even worse
uncivil she's trying to solve the wrong
problems while making the real problems
even
worse you know to summarize and to top
it all off she's attacking people for
not using their real names while she
herself does not use her real full name
she is not only an outof touch neocon
but also then a hypocrite and that is
why nimada Nikki Haley is today canceled
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcast